et le mouvement du convoi de la liberté
trouve un écho aussi en nouvelle zélande
cela free cela fait presque une semaine
maintenant que des manifestants opposés
aussi aux restrictions sanitaires
campent devant le parlement pas
découragé par le cyclone de vie qui a
entraîné ce dimanche les sauveteurs en
évacuation à travers le pays ils
demandent notamment la fin d'un
vaccination requises pour les personnes
travaillant dans certains secteurs comme
la santé
nous avons quatre enfants nous avons
deux voitures à payer nous avons un prêt
immobilier
nous avons beaucoup d'animaux et lorsque
nous avons perdu notre emploi prise de
l'obligation vaccinale et une samedi
nous allons perdre notre maison
nous avons tous des problèmes de santé
sous-jacents qui explique pourquoi nous
ne vivions pas du vaccin
je suis désolé mais dire à quelqu'un que
vous pouvez mourir en ayant ce vaccin on
perdre votre emploi je ne vois pas en
quoi c'est un choix
la générosité a été absolument
phénoménale et c'est ce qui a amené les
gens ici l'amour dans leur coeur à la
générosité ils veulent retrouver leur
père
j'ai assisté à quelques manifestations
dans ma vie mais je n'ai jamais ressenti
ça les gens veulent juste retrouver leur
vais vraiment et les gens sont tristes
lorsqu'ils ont perdu des membres de leur
famille ils ont perdu leur emploi ils
ont perdu leur business leur gagne pain
c'est fou